Film Courage: Mark, your new book (ASCREENWRITER’S
JOURNEY TO SUCCESS: Tips, tricks and tactics
to survive as a working screenwriter in Hollywood),
I understand from what you told me off camera,
it took you five years to actually write it?
Mark Sanderson: It did. I didn’t sit down
to write a book initially. I was blogging
and I wanted to get my past 20 years of professional
experience out of my mind and heart and try
to be able to share it with people. And so
after five or six years of blogging I realized
I had enough information to create something.
And so I started the process of stripping
down the articles and refabricating them into
chapters and then I thought “Well, I’m
going to chart my journey from how I started
in the business as a filmmakers at eleven
years old. What was that spark, that creative
spark? And chart it all the way until today.
Not so much as a memoir but also using examples
and funny anecdotal stories but disciplines
that I’ve used that have helped me stay
in the game that hopefully other writers will
be able to see and go “Oh, yeah? I’m not
doing that” or “I need to do that.”
Film Courage: Well you referenced a friend’s
grand father gave you a camera when you were
both around [age] eleven and that sparked
your love for making movies together. Have
you ever thought about what if that hadn’t
happened?
Mark Sanderson: Oh, yeah. I’m not sure…I
would have gone into some creative endeavor.
I wanted to be a cartoonist originally because
I love to draw and I still do. And in the
book, when I was writing the book, I drank
a lot of coffee and so it would leave a coffee
ring on the notes so I would do little doodles
and I’ve turned those into coffee ring mugs
and TV-shirts and things like that. But they’re
also in the book after every chapter. And
so I wanted to be a cartoonist or animator
or something creative. My parents eventually
bought me my own camera but it’s interesting
there are these times in your life that you
can only look back on now. I don’t know.
It would be interesting, I would do something
creative, absolutely. I was not going to be
a doctor (not that that was…), I was not
going to have a day job. I was going to do
something creative so I knew that because
my parents were always very supportive of
my brother and myself in the creative arts
and my brother is a graphic designer and he’s
always had the ability and talent for art.
So my parent, my dad wanted to be a singer
and he came out to Los Angeles from Michigan
in the early ‘60s and he would sing in piano
bars and he recorded little 45 records and
he wanted to be a singer and that was his
creative thing. But I always saw him doing
poetry and drawing and things like that.
And my mom artistically inclined with jewelry
making. And so I came from creative parents
but they came from an era where their parents
didn’t support them. You were going to get
a job in business or you were going to go
in a factory. It was just very clear cut.
And so I think they wanted to break that mold
and really supported my brother and I for
that and that’s so vitally important. In
the book I dedicate the book to my parents
because without them there would be no support
system. You know, that’s vital I think.
Film Courage: That’s beautiful.